ma credo credo credo che tu gli piaccia
messo qualcosa qui dentro vuole che
avevi tu
[Musica]
[Applauso]
dove andrai nascondo vitale devo farla
uscire da questa stanza in qualche modo
provo a distrarla
c'è di un libro per fortuna lessato qua
lo abbiamo recuperato ma ora dobbiamo
ritrovare vitale non so dove kissi mi si
avvia nascosto vitale c'è solo un modo
per saperlo chiamare i rinforzi e già
chiedere aiuto e sapete a chi all ex il
lupo next
un bisogno del tuo aiuto presto è
urgentissimo vitale è stato presto da
chi stilisti lo ha rinchiuso da qualche
parte ma non so dove sia chi siti sic i
chili si lo so forse non la conosci
perché non è nelle sfide creature del
libro è una creatura diversa è una nuova
creatura un nuovo cattivo però bisogno
del tuo aiuto perché devo assolutamente
salvare vitale ok aspetto ritenuto
questa kissi missy che aspetto come
faccio a riconoscerlo e allora te lo
spiego subito
è un pupazzo gigante così lino molto più
alto bello quanto tecniche altissimo per
caso ti poco di e poi è tutta rosa ed è
pelosa rosa rosa peloso alta ok va bene
uno scrigno è capito se sì lo fa che
dalla descrizione sembra qualcosa di
supercar in osx europa ti assicuro che
quando la vedrai ti farò paura voto
perché ha un sorriso molto ma l'etica
poi vuole mandarci
molto bene molto bene con noi e poi in
giro incalza che gironzola e ti stai
cercando ok ok ok ok adesso adesso non
facciamoci prendere la guida non
facciamoci prendere dal panico allora
pensiamo pensiamo io non la conosco non
è una creatura del libro ma io non so
cosa possiamo fare per libro magari a
una risposta a una soluzione
ospiti io credo che l'unica soluzione
sia che la pro dito io lo sapete io ho
io
me lo sento
e poi ce ne sono allora sono esattamente
le giudicare dal sole sono le cinque
quindi chi io temo scapolo l'unità il
mio io non posso trovarmi del vento uomo
mezzo
agli atti e ai tutto non posso
affrontarla io ho troppo forte per me ma
per i turisti a farlo sì ma mezzo uomo
ed all 1 sono né uno né l'altro a meno
sei in tutto sei tutta umana ce la puoi
fare io non me la sento poi alle 5 io
prendo il tè subitamente prendo quindi
gravissimo una cassetta vabbè grazie per
il non aiuto l'ex
vai pure a prendere il tè e dovrò
arrangiarmi è sconfiggere che
significato la ok mi dispiace quindi io
non posso aiutarti da come viene
descritta si sembra un pochino un
pericolo un buon provocate quindi
perdonami anita io in questo caso lo
saprei proprio come aiutati quindi se
siamo a posto qui io credevo che i lupi
fossero più coraggio ancora però tempo
non è paura e guido prendere il tè alle
cinque qui certo vai una giornata
comunque ciao
e propria scappato possibile che anche
l'ex abbia paura di chi si misti non ha
neanche mai vista un'idea forse nel
libro troverò comunque qualche risposta
anche se non c'è la scheda creatura di
chi si missy avete lasciato mi piace mi
raccomando lasciate un mi piace qui
sotto
vediamo se troviamo qualcosa
ma
ma non è d'aiuto
[Applauso]
cosa sta succedendo
che schifo
lei chi si
[Musica]
dimette
aiuto
ma
che
schifo
[Musica]
di un passo la salita anche cosa foglie
marito allora adesso io cercherò di
aiutarti ma aspetta
bovino in
[Musica]
generale dovere o potrano a chi ti ho
detto aiutami sconfiggere in qualche
modo
[Musica]
credo credo che gli piaccia
credo che tu le piaccia
si sta comportando in modo
non sei proprio il mio tipo no dico di
come far vivere ai troppi più veloci di
me guarda guarda guarda te
mi sembra che agli stilisti non gliene
freghi niente che che tu la vuoi
[Musica]
cosa bisogna fare il verso al bar di
abilità grazie all ex e l'abruzzo
sta succedendo cosa ha preso
è un regalo
ho deciso di farsi per me questo per me
sarai anche bruttina però si molto dolce
[Applauso]
sì ma è comunque non è il mio tipo si
pronto
come reagirà
no niente non voglio aggiungere troppi
d'italia
lo accetto però tu non mi mangi va bene
non mi ami
che non ho detto sì e no
no no
carini
[Musica]
ok
ho capito ho capito che piaccia
davvero mi dispiace per te l'ex ma è
veramente divertente questa situazione
non mi sarei mai aspettata che gli
stilisti si sarebbe innamorata di te
come pensi che possiamo fare allora può
essere un vantaggio perché se li
innamorata di te non ti farò del male
credo puoi fare finta di essere
innamorato di lei e poi tu che conosci
molto bene i poteri del libro storie
paurose puoi trovare un incantesimo un
qualcosa che che la faccia sparire o
qualcosa del genere però l'importante è
che lei non capisca che tu stai cercando
di eliminarla altrimenti si arrabbierà
tantissimo ok ok ho un'idea credo di
poterti liberare più gli artigli
ciao ciao
di fatto abbia fatto a un bel non
capisco cosa stia facendo
e cosa sta facendo ma quella tanta
ma io mi ha detto di parti lese ha messo
qualcosa qui dentro vuole che l'abilità
io per lei
che cosa vuoi fare
non mi piace troppo l'idea
credo che se non la vedi io figlio molto
male anche vitale che non abbiamo ancora
dov'è rinchiuso mi dire meglio meno bene
va bene avere molta fatica ma
vorrei anche che ti sbrighi
grazie l'ex mister di sacrificare la per
bevuto quell'intruglio
dei coloratissimi ti
disgusto lei come ti senti l'ex non
sento nessun cambiamento
credo fosse un tè uno di quindi un pò
esotici ah ok meno male non era niente
di strano tipo una pozione veleno forte
male non
è
detto che finiti ma è meglio il meglio
che il piano ben normale che anche se
lei un po malefica non so che cosa ti ha
architettato
io sono libera ma ora faccio finta di
essere ancora legate al momento giusto
capiamo però proprio come da piano conto
sul tuo aiuto l'ex mi raccomando tu
sarai fondamentale tube ma sai
che accettare qui i conti sinisi
ma che stai dicendo lei che finissi ma
l'hai vista è bellissima
ma
[Musica]
l'ex impazzito di aver trovato l'amore
della mia vita perché ci si è visti il
pupazzo candini
[Musica]
porno che cosa è successo all'ex forse
queste che ha bevuto gli ha fatto
qualcosa
[Musica]
forse lei ha preparato una pozione
d'amore perché chi stimi si vedeva che
l'eta non era minimamente interessata a
lei ce ne andremo ci muoveremo una
bellissima vita insieme
che schifo
la soluzione un libro emessa taro
chiesti messi e molto di strada adesso
dall ex
creare un antidoto con il libro
non sono brava come l'ex degli
incantesimi col libro ma ci provo libro
poi tornare l'ex normale
normale
credo che sia successo qualcosa forse
questo è l'antidoto oppure potrebbe
essere qualcosa di mostruoso che fa
trasformare sia chi si mitiche l'ex ma
sbagliamo che sia l'antidoto è ora devo
solo trovare il modo di farlo per e
all'ex
m l'ex c'è chi si è visti entrambi
anziché series ti senti non hai paura
che l'effetto della pozione d'amore
svanisca
beh se svanisce un gran problema perché
l'ex si ricorderà che le fa estiva o
quindi è meglio che metteva ancora un
pochettino non credi
dice
anche dall ex boy berne altra vero vuoi
essere ancora più innamorato di casey
visti vero
[Risate]
è lì lì pronta dai baby food che ti
[Applauso]
[Risate]
sei bravo bravissimo bravissimo che se
mi sei da nino marino mido benefici
fichi medi subito adesso merita
questo ed altro
vedo male speriamo che faccia a faccia
su disco amore mio
[Applauso]
amico
hague ha fatto un incantesimo l'ho
finalmente trasformata in quello che è
un pupazzo
[Applauso]
ce l'abbiamo fatto adesso non potrà più
farci del male o troppo forti
ce l'ha
[Musica]
aiutato il libro ei ma ora dobbiamo
dobbiamo liberare in italia non sappiamo
spirito liberiamoci di chi si avvia
andiamo a cercare di tale vero andiamo
andiamo fisico ci può far guidare
benissimo
ciao con i galaxy sono venuti posto sul
corso grazie sono stato io l'ho
sconfitta che gli abbiamo fatto non
serve
lardo che cosa avete fatto
ma adesso non fa più paura anzi detto ho
sempre schifo per ora
grazie all'incantesimo del libro alex
riuscito a sconfiggere kissi misti e
trasformarla in un botto e voi l'avete
già preso scrivetevi
[Applauso]
[Musica]
kiss
[Applauso]
[Musica]